so it is thursday evening in iceland
i had two games today
i just finished my round three game but
i'm going to go ahead and do my round
two recap
from this morning i played grand master
aliban
from india
he's a pretty well known player and i
imagine a lot of viewers would recognize
his name
he's been featured in a few of my videos
most prominently
we played this kind of banter trash talk
game and the staffer gambit
back in july in sochi
so i'll link that below if you guys want
to see
a more uh more casual type game
but here we played a serious classical
game
and it was my first time playing aliban
in a
created otb game
and he played e4
and i had a little bit of time to
prepare last night the pairings went up
sometime around like 9 or 10 or 11 pm
um already forgetting but
it was a 9 a.m round this morning so
i didn't prepare too much just because i
wanted to get enough sleep
and i decided to play the sicilian
and aliban recently came out with a
lifetime repertoire course
in 1e4 for white
and in that course he recommends knight
f3
and that was the main thing i was
preparing for him but in the game he
surprised me with the move pawn c3 going
for an alepan sicilian
and after the game i jokingly told him
that that i thought he mouse slipped
upon b3 because he's known for playing
this move as well
uh the so-called cowboy system or
whatever this is
but uh pawn c3 it's not a move that i
have studied
so recently
but uh i do have experience in in this
line as a sicilian player now i also
want to mention that after the game he
he was telling me that uh it would have
been funny if i had played the stafford
but i told him it would be a bit too
predictable
so the game continued from here i play
pawn d5
this is one of the main lines
alternative is knight f6 but the point
of pawn d5 is after it takes and takes
because white has committed the pawn to
c3 there's no knight c3 so this is one
of the most reputable lines for black
and after d4 i have six knife three this
is all opening preparation
uh knight a3 was played knight a3 is a
tricky move
um if i'm not mistaken i think
there is some like hand in brain between
ludwig and magnus against the botest
sisters i'm pretty sure they had this
exact position i'll have to check it
though i'm going to get nuts
love it that's what i wanted to do
they say
um but this is kind of mainline theory
and white has ideas of knight b5 and the
vlog's not careful then it can be easy
to get into trouble
but thankfully i was still pretty
prepared here played knight c6
and the point is if knight b5 right away
i can very simply move back to d8
and if bishop f4 threatening knight c7
then i have the nice move knight d5
hitting the bishop and defending c7
so instead of going for this line
aniban played bishop to e3
which i think is a more
uh testing move for white to try and get
the advantage
and now white has ideas of taking and
trying to win a pawn because that would
open up the
file for the queen trade
and here i take
and knight b5
and
i think this is still some opening
preparation on my part but it's been
years since i looked at this line
so at some point i was just on my own
after queen d8
takes takes
and uh yeah bishop takes d4 i had some
big memories of knight takes d4 but
bishop takes d4 was a new move for me
and here i started thinking um because
there are a few different options for
black
now the most obvious move
and i'm checking the database here the
most played move too is bishop to e7
which maybe i should have played
um i didn't play bishop e7 because after
bishop to
d3 white has ideas of knight e5 and i
thought it would be a little bit
passive for black because it's hard to
develop this bishop so actively like if
i play b6 here i'm pretty sure 95 and i
have to worry about queen f3 and bishop
b5 check and knight c6
so i was already sensing a little bit of
danger
and
instead of going for bishop e7 i went
for
a more
[Music]
perhaps active move queen d5
and the point of this was to
in some sense stay flexible because i
wasn't sure where my bishop wants to
develop to whether it goes to e7 d6 or
c5
and i'm also pinning the knight
in some sense to the g2 pawn because
after the bishop develops knight would
be pinned to g2 and i wasn't scared of
this line because i could throw in queen
digs d1
and
even though i have double pawns black is
probably for choice with the bishop hair
so uh
here adiban played queen b3 which i
think is a very sensible move going for
a queen trade and i don't want to take
because that would just strengthen
mike's position and open a file
so i deliver a check on e4
and after bishop e2
now i play bishop d7 and i'm getting
ready to castle
and up until this point i was feeling
pretty good
especially because the queen is
essentially tying down the king to
defending the bishop
like can't castle either way
which would just leave the bishop
hanging
and i thought it's up to white to solve
some of the issues here
and
aliban played a move which
i think i saw but i just completely
underestimated and i think it turned out
to be
a really strong move here is knight to
d2
uh basically showing me that the knight
wasn't
fully pinned to the g2 pawn
and this is a very temporary pawn
sacrifice but it does lead to a trailer
pawns after i take on g2
white wins back upon after bishop f3
move my queen
after takes takes takes
this was all relatively forcing from
knight d2
and now
my rook is hit and i can't castle i
would love to castle but now my king is
the one tied down to the bishop
so there's basically only one move here
for black to try and keep things
offended which is queen to d5 i should
note my queen has just moved a lot of
times in opening i have defied
some basic principles my queen has moved
one two three four five six times
uh in the first 16 moves but uh okay
queen d5 is very much justified here
and adiban went ahead and took
and here it looks like my next move
should be played pretty quickly
but i ended up taking a long think
in this position
trying to decide whether to take the
pawn
or the knight
and unfortunately
it's a really difficult decision because
black is already a little bit worse here
and i will admit i haven't checked this
game so closely with engine so i don't
know
entirely where i went wrong
leading up to this point but
this was a really uncomfortable decision
to make because
if i take with pawn
then this pawn on d5 is just going to be
a long-term weakness white has rook g1
probably forcing g6 and then after
queensland castling
yeah this d5 pawn at the right moment uh
white's probably gonna plan to take on
f6
uh maybe first play knife three and then
go after d5 and i thought i would be
very likely to lose a pawn
eventually in this variation
so i ultimately decided to
lose a pawn right away
by taking with a knight on d5
and uh yeah even though i lose a g7 pawn
here i thought there are some chances to
get initiative and some counter play
because white does have to spend some
time moving the bishop
so um yeah he very quickly snagged the
pawn on g7 i played rook g8
and then he played a very nice move
rather than just retreating all the way
back to d4 he played bishop to e5
which is a very useful square for the
bishop because it prevents me from
accessing the b file my queenside rook
and it also has some tricks like if i go
in too deep with rook g2
then there's bishop g3 and my rook is
getting trapped next move due to king f1
i should also note bishop e5
is prophylaxis against knight f4 which
is a move i really wanted to play to get
some
quadruple fork potential but
um yeah my knight is very much
restricted in this position
so i went ahead and played pawn f6 made
the bishop move another time and
here i wanted to play pawn f5 to trap
the bishop but unfortunately white can
just return to e5
and
only thing accomplished here is the fact
that i've weakened the e5 square
so rather than going for that i just
improved my queenside rook
to c8
and
i still felt like i have some
sort of compensation
but it was really hard to prove in the
game
and this is one of the downsides of just
being down the pawn is it's basically up
to me to try and create counter play
and uh from mike's perspective he just
wanted to stay solid and eventually
simplify
game continued from here queenside
castling
i played rook to g4
trying to create some ideas of swinging
the rook all the way over to a4
also had ideas of h5 h4 to still try and
trap the bishop so i was trying to stay
flexible
but he played a very natural move rook
to e1 hitting the pawn
and also having an idea after king f7 is
to play rook e4
just neutralizing my rook
and
i realized that rook g4 didn't
accomplish so much
and now i either have to trade
immediately
or defend my rook
i thought about trading for a bit
because after takes takes i do have the
move upon f5
threatening the knight and also
threatening to trap the bishop but
unfortunately here there's knight d6
and this is just forcing trains and
white's still
up a pretty clean pawn so
i decided to play pawn h5
trying to keep some tension
uh now f3 was played after takes takes
i went into e3 with the knight packing
the rook
he played rook 2 e1
and i defend the knights with bishop c5
so
yeah i'm still down the pawn but i i
still felt hopeful that uh
the activity between the bishop and the
knight would create some some
compensation
but he played a really solid move here
rook to e2
just solidifying the
whole territory for white and it's
actually hard to find a plan for black
in this position i decided to play pawn
a5
with some idea of eventually pushing all
the way to a3 to undermine the queen
side structure
and here bishop f2 was played
and i was actually hoping that he would
play bishop f2 during the game because i
have a cool move
knight g2 with the point that
if bishop takes bishop it looks like
white's just winning a piece but i have
a clever inter-messo knight f4 hitting
the rook and repairing knight d3
white's still probably better here after
a move like rookie 3 or rook f2
but
we didn't go into this
after knight g2 we just repeated we
played bishop g3 i moved my knight back
to e3
and then
instead of repeating a third time which
i would have been really happy with
he played the move knight to b3
which i think is a very effective way of
making progress in the position
because now i have
a bunch of targets that are under
pressure from white's pieces
and
i have to be careful not to lose even
more material and the only move i saw to
keep everything defended was knight to
c4
if i move the bishop back to
e6 or a7 then the bishop's no longer
defended and bishop f2
should be winning material for white
after a line like this
takes takes and takes
so
i did play knight c4
defending the pawn
and after takes takes
still now the pawn but unfortunately
this is where white begins making
very steady progress uh starting with
pawn b3
taking away my knight
now my knights restricted all these
squares are pretty much off limits i
didn't want to play knight e5
i thought this was just a losing um king
rook ending after
king d2
and
eventually the king's gonna walk up the
pawn is gonna
push white house ideas of a3 b4
and i didn't see too much hope here
so i went back to b6
and after king c2
um it was just really hard to find
active moves for black
my knight was severely misplaced being
restricted by the pawn i tried to
reroute it with knight to c8 and my plan
here was to play e5 and knight d6 to
try and create some weakness on e4
but he played really well here starting
with c4 i played e5
and now rook d2
and this move prevents knight d6 but it
also prepares the move rook d5 which is
just really hard to stop
and i ended up allowing it with move
king e6 and after rook t5
i either have to trade rooks or retreat
and lose another pawn
i decided to trade but after takes
we are entering a an end game which
is completely winning for white
and um the technique from aliban was uh
it was just flawless here i don't think
there were any uh any mistakes on his
part in that game after bishop e1 this
pawn is very weak i tried to get some
counter play with my king
but after king d3
i'm a little bit boxed out all these
squares are off limits
uh so i played knight to d6 and after
takes i played f5
and uh nice move from white pawn b4
um driving my king away from the center
and now after takes takes king e4
weiss was making clear progress forking
my knight and my pawn with the king
and i played on because sometimes
knights can be tricky in these scenarios
but uh
it didn't last long um before white was
able to
convert this for a win after knight h6
takes
knight g4 the king walks up upon walks
up
and
i was going for one last trick in the
position
uh
we got to this position after knight c6
controlling the d8 square
and i was really hoping that
white would queen here
after which the position would become a
draw
due to takes takes and takes
and i'll be winning the pawn
or
or i could even just run into the corner
this is just a theoretical draw if the
king gets to the eighth square because
the bishop is of the wrong color
but uh this didn't happen
unfortunately for me adiman played pawn
a4
very nice move making use of
another white pawn in the position and
here i just resigned my king is going to
be driven away from the knight
and yeah this is game over
so
i think it was a very clean game on
white's parts
i'm not sure if anybody made any like
clear
mistakes or inaccuracies this game
and i don't even know where i went wrong
this game
it could have been some small moments in
the opening
but um
yeah i may have just stumbled into
like a really uncomfortable line and i
think all it took was
a few subtle mistakes for the position
to just go downhill
so i did intentionally share this game
without any engine analysis
because i think it's um
it can be a healthy approach to
to review games without the engine first
and then take a look at the engine later
and
then have a better idea of what's going
on in the position
so for those that want to analyze this
game in more depth i will leave a link
in the description to my leachat study
where i'm saving all my games from this
tournament i'll also leave links to the
official touring website hearings and
standings
uh the official live broadcast
and uh and yeah i hope you guys enjoyed
this video
kudos to aliban for playing a really
nice game i'll leave audibon's uh
chessball courses and his
youtube channel also in the description
you can check them out
and again thanks for watching and i'll
see you in the next video